MEME REVIEW BABY
Welcome everyone to meme review
Yeah, im a gamer.
(strugles) cheat on my wife. (poor Marzia)
I'm sure everybody has already heard
And I know, it devastated me
It shshhhhh shook me to my core
ProJared cheated on his wife?! (GASP?)
What The Frick dude
I used to love his Nintendo review
WhAT?
The man that looks exactly like the guy from lost
Cheated on his wi, WHAT unbelievelble!
So the wife uuuuh, apparently spared no
she didnt held back...
(Gives up because of the failure, twice)
Saying  (quote on screen (blurred is fricking))
Felix: "I have proof, I have evidence and hes gonna DIE"
Even going after
the person he cheated with
Jesus Christ
okay (okay?)
And everything just happened at once then.
pictures of.
you know what i dont wanna get into the details
That's for PEW NEWS (the most News News show)
♪ Pewnews intro starts       ♪
I think what's important here, is the memes
okay? (okidoki)
I don't really care about anything else right now
I just wanna go Haha
Thank god i'm not the one in the controversy today
(3 weeks cmon we can make it)
Haha look at that guy, he messed up
you know when you messed up
when Dsp out of all people drags you on twitter
(Can someone tell me who dsp is in the comments cause im cluelless?)
Projarad: Yes,
I shouldn't have cheated
and i'm okay with that
And that's why my final rating for this (pews giggle)
Is a broken marriage/10
ooohoohohohohoho ( oh hey santa)
So if you'll excuse me
I need to delete some pictures of myself playing naked
uuuuhwwwwwwww
Felix: you didn't delete the..
ProJarad: unless you wanna see em?
Felix: Noooooooooo
DELETE THEM
DELETE THEM PROJARAD PLEASE
Felix repeating:That's why I rate this broken marriage/10
God damn it Projared, He was leaving this hint all along!
Why did we not listen to him?
WE SHOULD HAVE LISTENED
His most viewed video,
How to make slender not scary
^^
What?!
Even ProJared's on mods joined in
In the Slaughtering that has been Projared
(He says the memes,)
(So i kinda dont know what to do)
(I guess just fill space)
(mmm well ill just wait till Felix says something)
Felix: Oh its Gamer time (back to business)
I think what's funny about this is how JohnTron
You know the guy that was kicked out of their collective group
For uhh saying things, i don't know exactly what he said
But BAD THINGS he said BAD THINGS
(felix is saying the meme again)
(So there is more empty space huh)
Felix: I guess he got the last laugh
ProJared loosing hundreds..
Hundred thousand subscribers in just one day
Just after hitting a million subs
(Felix: reading the meme again)
(SO MUCH EMPTY SPACE)
I used to watch his videos back in the day
Maybe like 4 or 3 years ago or something
They are not bad videos
I don't really care (suuure Felix)
I just want the ( ̶M̶o̶n̶e̶y̶) Memes
Look he looks just like him!
HAhahaha
I like the fact that.. Whatever.. Go to any picture
Loading dialog.exe
On his instagram
It's all clowns. It's just clowns
Yall got Clowned on
You unlocked clown outfit
Woaahie
Now it's worth mentioning
We haven't fully heard Jared's side of his story
And a lot of things are bothering me about this whole thing
There is a lot of puzzle pieces that dont make sence to me
I don't think both parties are completely blameless here
But thats for Poppy Gloria to decide
In her video, thats probably coming up tommorow
♪ Pew News intro ♪
Moving on ProJared gets a broken marriage/10
Next MEME